but to be pouting on the bench making
faces not cheering your teammates on
when we're down eight the entire game
come back and go up by three and you're
not celebrating that I'm gonna tell you
something
fellas I was that guy I was 100 million
dollar guy
I was powering I was upset when I wasn't
playing and I had a bad attitude I went
from 100 million dollars to a league
minimum it's a personal story I'm
sharing with you guys right now they
don't care how many rebounds you get how
many threes you make they care about you
being as a person are you a good
teammate are you good locker room guy
are you someone that can count on each
and every night I talk about consistency
you play 100 every single time you step
on that floor
consistency fellas consistency